[Musique]
David l'appartient bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le président de la Fédération
Française de Cyclisme président depuis
assez récemment de l'Union européenne de
cyclisme et là nous sommes à à
Saint-Quentin en Eveline où vient
d'aménager la Fédération il il y a
quelques temps devant devant cette piste
de BMX hein
euh le fait d'être ici à côté du
vélodrome de Saint-Quentin c'est un
projet que vous vous portez depuis
longtemps je crois ah c'est un projet
que je porte depuis depuis le début
depuis la candidature finalement de
Paris aux Jeux Olympique de 2012 j'étais
en son temps vice-président de la
délégué de la fédération et j'ai suivi
ce dossier de depuis début dans tous les
comités de pilotage et j'ai toujours
porté ce projet parce qu'il était
ambitieux pour notre pays ambitieux pour
notre fédération ambitieux pour le
territoire et ça positionne notre sport
et notre fédération à un autre niveau
que ce qu'on avait l'habitude avant
alors là c'est vrai que tout est
regrouper c'estàdire que il y a en effet
la la Fédération toutes les instances de
la fédération mais il y a aussi bah les
équipes de France qui viennent
s'entraîner ici il y a aussi des
amateurs et on voit des gens qui qui
traversent qui viennent ici c'est-à-dire
que le lien au fond entre entre le
cyclisme amateur le cyclisme
professionnel et et la Fédération il se
fait ici quoi il il se fait ici parce
que l'idée était clair c'était on devait
avoir un équipement du top niveau
mondial mais qui soit aussi accessible
au grand public et c'est possible pour
un certain nombre de de nos disciplines
le vélodrome qu'il soit pour le grand
public ou pour le haut niveau c'est le
même au niveau de la piste et donc
c'était vraiment l'ambition et de la
fédération et des élus locaux de faire
en sorte qu'il ait une ambition
internationale nationale bien sûr franç
ilienne et puis aussi locale au niveau
de la l'agglomération de 5 an nveline
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a dimensionné
ça et pensé dès le début pour que il
puisse rencontrer tous ses publics les
athlètes des équipes de France la
compétition régionale monsieur madame
tout le monde pour le loisir et les
écoliers parce que c'était aussi
important que les écoliers et voyez
cette piste de BMX qui est derrière nous
bien on voit qu' elle a finalement deux
couloirs un pour déjà de la compétition
de niveau régional et un pour
l'international
on a faire des équip dimensionnés à
double niveau c'était ça votre projet au
fond de de lier bah le le sport loisir
et puis le le sport de de très haut
niveau c'était c'était une partie
effectivement du projet nous avions
besoin à la Fédération d'un équipement
de top niveau mondial pour que nos
coureurs nos athlètes nos potentiels
médaill olympique soient dans des
conditions de jeux olympiques donc pour
ça il fallait le meilleur équipement au
monde mais si demain on ne forme pas la
relève si on permet pas à des jeunes de
venir découv notre sport et bien on a
aussi sans doute pas réussi complètement
ce qu'on souhaitait donc c'est pour ça
d'emblé il y a eu cette cette
ambition de réfléchir pour l'ensemble
des niveaux est-ce que les les résultats
c'est fabuleux qu'on vient d'avoir au
championnat du monde Françis pervice
notamment est-ce que bah ça a déjà une
influence làdessus est-ce qu' on peut
dire que ça ça un lien de cause eff ou
est-ce que ça extrapolé de dire ça je
pense qu'il y a une dynamique globale
qui s'est mis en place et la dynamique
vous savez ça ça se mesure pas c'est pas
toujours
quantifiable et et je pense que
l'arrivée dans ce vélodrome prenons
l'exemple de François Pervis que vous
venez de citer il habite ici il habite
maintenant ici à montinil Bretonneux il
habitait dans un petit 25 m²r il
s'entraînait à l'INSP aujourd'hui il a
pris un appartement beaucoup plus grand
euh il il est venu en famille et puis
bah il a un lieu d'entraînement
absolument extraordinaire il habite à
côté ce vélodrome lui permett dans des
vraies conditions de course même s'il y
a été que de mois avant les championnats
du monde pour pour autant la la
dynamique la dynamique est là et je
pense que dans le sport tout n'est pas
que rationnel il y a aussi des
dynamiques et et aujourd'hui elle roule
pour nous alors la Fédération Française
de Cyclisme c'est le cyclisme sur route
naturellement c'est le BMX come on le
voit c'est la piste c'est le Vél
cross tout tout ça tout ça ça fait
beaucoup d'activités quand même même si
c'est tout ça c'est le vélo quand même
tout ça c'est le vélo tout ça c'est la
fédération mais c'est vrai que sont des
disciplines complètement variées
diverses et qui sont comp élémentaire
mais qu'on retrouve ici à Saint-Quentin
euh j'en veux pour preuve que nos
équipes de France sur route leur premier
stage de l'équipe de France dame dès le
début janvier il a été ici ils sont
parlé parti tout de suite rouler dans la
vallée de Chevreuse voilà il y a pas que
les hommes donc il y a les hommes et les
femmes donc l'équipe de France rout a
trouvé ses quartiers ici l'équipe de
France de BMX l'équipe de France sur
piste on a prévu de tracer un circuit
permanent de cyclocross sur la colline
des lancour il y aura un lieu de
pratique de VTT donc nous aurons toutes
les disciplines du cyclisme toutes les
disciplines de notre fédération sur un
même et unique site c'est tout
simplement unique au monde formable
unique au monde oui uniqueonde et ça
veut dire que probablement bah des
événements qui avaient lieu ailleurs
peut-être auront-ils lieu ici enfin des
événements mondiaux je veux dire c'est
l'ambition c'est que qu'on accueille
aussi qu'on a une politique d'accueil de
grands événements internationaux on on
va commencer cette année avec un
championnat de France sur piste un
championnat de France de BMX ici pour
montrer que a nous y sommes on peut
accueillir ces événements mais
l'ambition elle est de passer sur des
championnats d'Europe et des
championnats du monde on va dire très
rapidement parce que bah tout est fait
pour qu'il en soit ainsi alors ce projet
vous le disiez vous le portez depuis
depuis 2008 quand vousz encore
vice-président de de la Fédération c'est
votre côté vous êtes du morbillon hein
donc c'est votre côté breton comme ça ah
c'est le côté si vous voulez on ne lâche
pas sur des dossiers des dossiers comme
ça j'ai sans doute cru plutôt que les
autres parce que j'ai vu vraiment des
élus locaux de toute sensibilité mais
qui éta qui étaient vraiment ici moteur
dans le dossier alors ça c'est important
quand les élus sont moteur nous mononde
cycliste on n pas le droit d'être en
retard j'ai parfois été un petit peu
seul au début à la Fédération vous savez
ça faisait 55 ans qu'on attendait ça
depuis la démolition du veldive et du
coup on nous a fait tellement de
promesses tellement de lieux où on
devait atterrir où on est jamais allé
que nos dirigeants disent oh vous savez
on en a vu d'autres on nous en a
tellement promis que celui-là ça va
faire comme les autres dit je pense pas
j'étais peut-être pas làavant mais je
pense pas parce qu'il y a une vraie
détermination et au final tout le monde
s'est rallié à à cette idée il y a une
vraie fierté des membres de notre
fédération d'être ici au centre national
au Vélodrome national de 50 Ansel alors
j'ai un petit peu les contributions que
vous avez publié quand vous êtes
présenté Fédération Française l'Union
européenne vous insistez beaucoup sur
des mots comme l'éthique la
morale c'est important pour vous je
c'est important pour le cyclisme parce
que c'est vrai qu'il est toujours
balloté entre un immense succès public
au fond et puis bah des scandales qui
qui voit le
jourant ENF bien sûr on a on a vraiment
souffert et encore dans le grand public
aujourd'hui dopage égal cyclisme alors
que finalement nous sommes nous avons
effectivement voilà nous avons eu
beaucoup plus de de de souci les autres
c'est vrai il faut reconnaître notre
sport s'est égaré à un certain moment
pour autant aujourd'hui on pourrait dire
que nous sommes le sport de l'antidopage
réellement les efforts sont beaucoup
plus importants qu'ailleurs il y a une
vraie volonté politique et nous ne
pouvions pas non plus avec l'image de la
Fédération engager cette fédération sans
que ces valeurs là soient au cœur même
du des projet et de notre projet donc
pour nous la morale l'éthique la
crédibilité des résultats sportifs c'est
quelque chose d'essentiel est-ce qu'il
faut aller fouiller dans le passé on l'
fait par exemple je pense à à Jalabert
qui était sélectionneur national qui a
dû démissionner est-ce qu'il faut aller
remonter comme ça très loin dans le
passé ou est-ce qu'il faut s'occuper de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui à votre avis
alors je pense que il faut expurger ce
passé une fois pour toutes c'est le but
de la commission indépendante de réforme
du cyclisme qui a mis en place Bran
coxson au niveau international le mandat
il est du 1er janvier 2000 1998 jusqu'au
31 décembre 2013 on va une fois pour
toutes faire la lumière sur cette
période làà et après on sera résolument
tourné vers le futur pour autant la
manière dont s'est passé l'affire
galaberre n'est pas digne d'un pays
démocratique comme le note où on donne
en pâture des noms comme cela surtout
provenant de sénateur qui pour certains
n'avaient qu'une seule ambition de se
faire mousser je trouve ça assez
grotesque de la manière dont ça s'est
passé s'il y avait des choses qu'elles
soit révélé c'est d'un commission
d'enquête
on qu' soit étouffé mais Don un seul nom
en peinture en disant venez voir le
rapport dans 15 jours vous aurez la
suite et finalement les 60 propositions
des sénateurs personne s'en souvient
tout le monde se souvient de l'annexe 2
où il donnait les noms des contrevenants
accessoirement que dans le vélo puisque
la FIFA c'était par exemple assuré que
les flacons de la Coupe du Monde 98
étaient bien détruits ils étaient venu
voir personnellement que les flacons
étaient détruits donc voilà traitons t
les sport de la même manière ouais il y
a il y a quand même ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est dire que il y a eu
ces soupçons voilà sur le dopage mais il
y a on voit Tour de France enfin on
pourrait le voir dans dans dans toutes
les disciplines il y a un formidable
élan populaire pour le pour le pour le
cyclisme comment vous l' expliquer ça
moi je pense que le cyclisme il est
profondément enraciné dans la culture
française et que finalement quand on
voit tous les scandale qu'on a eu on se
dit mais il devrait plus y avoir un
spectateur dans les courses de vélo il y
a jamais autant de monde je suis
dimanche dernier dans une course certes
dans le morbillan un département qui
m'est cher course amateur 12000
personnes il y avait 12000 personnes à
Manche Atlantique certes une des plus
belles classiques mais quand même je
n'ai jamais vu autant de monde dans une
course amateur donc on a de plus en plus
de monde dans les courses de vélo et et
ça montre que il y a un attachement réel
qui se transmet de génération en
génération et c'est ce qui fait
finalement la force de ce sport vous
êtes toujours pour le tour de fond pour
le retour des équipes nationales alors
ça a un peu décrié la la chronique quand
j'ai proposé ça parce que je trouvais
que cet événement il est tellement
planétaire que euh au final on a vu
aussi parfois sont les équipes de marque
qui nous ont envoyé dans certains
certainsement et que si on voulait
retrouver un engouement populaire
beaucoup plus fort je suis convaincu que
les équipes nationales sont une un moyen
de pouvoir le faire regardons les Coupes
du Monde de football les Jeux Olympiques
euh quand les athlètes ou les
compétiteurs prennent le maillot
national comme on est tous patriotes on
est tous encore plus mobilisé donc
c'était une manière de de développer
encore ce sport ça pas forcément été été
bien compris mais c'est un peu utopique
aujourd'i peut-être un peu utopique mais
je suis convaincu que un événement phare
sous équipe nationale c'est peut-être
aussi une manière de développer toutes
les autres épreuves parce que le
rayonnement sera beaucoup plus
planétaire tous les championnats du
monde se déroulent comme ça
et tout le mond quel été alors vous êtes
très vite engagé vous avez fait vousmême
du du véloin vous êtes très vite engagé
dans le dans les responsabilité dans les
clubs locaux la la
Fédération pourquoi pour
l'envie de servir un peu l'envie de
servir moi je l'avais depuis VO oui je
suis aussi maire et conseiller général
j'ai toujours eu envie de servir euh et
et cette ce sport il il m'est très cher
j'avais en fin finalement de lui rendre
un peu ce que ce qu'il m'a apporté je
savais que j'avais pas le niveau pour
passer courur professionnel pour être un
grand coureur mais je me disais j'ai
peut-être le niveau pour servir mon
sport d'une autre manière et j'ai été
élu très jeune à la Fédération puisque
j'ai été élu à 23 ans au comité
directeur à l'époque de la Fédération je
suis le plus jeune président de
fédérationlympique qui es élu à 35 ans
rélu à 39 ans et et je pense que voilà
on peut être élu relativement jeune dans
des fonctions qui sont des fonctions
bénévole il faut aussi le le rappeler
mais j'avais vraiment envie de de servir
mon sport de lui rendre finalement ces
lettes de noblesse et devrait pour son
développement et j'espère bah il
contribuer modestement mais mais mais
très sincèrement alors vous avez encore
4 an de mond 3 ans he 3 ans de mandat
voilà qu'est-ce qu'on peut qu'est-ce
qu'on peut souhaiter vous souhaitez à
vous puis c'est souhaitz au sport ciste
de façon générale alors je pense que le
sport cycliste il faut qu'on lui
souhaite la le retour de la crédibilité
c'est vraiment sur sur la bonne voie à
la Fédération Française de Cyclisme moi
je souhaite que bah nous soyons qu'on
retrouve une place tout à fait leader
voire peut-être la première au niveau
des Jeux olympiques de Rio c'est notre
objectif majeur et qu'on retrouve aussi
une équipe et un vainqueur potentiel du
Tour de France il est peut-être pas
encore c'est un voilà je pense qu'on
avant la fin de votre mandat allez sais
pas ENF si Onura le vainqueur du Tour de
France français avant la fin du mandat
je ne pense pas pour autant on l'aura
peut-être déjà dans les équipes
professionnelles françaises et notre
ambition maintenant après l'achèvement
de ce ce vélodrome national c'est
l'avènement d'une équipe professionnelle
appartenant à la Fédération de très haut
niveau mondial ça c'est le le futur
grand projet c'est tout ce qu'on vous
souhaite merci beaucoup Dav merci
[Musique]
bien y